but we're going to begin with the news
which is that major development multiple
major developments in fact in the murder
trial of disgraced attorney Alec
murdaugh in South Carolina yesterday I'm
sure you were watching he took the stand
and denied killing his wife denied
killing his son to cover up alleged
Financial crimes and today his
cross-examination will continue and
prosecutors are expected to press him
hard after he admitted to lying to
investigators Nikki Batista is following
the trial in Walterboro South Carolina
as she has been for days they're lining
up already Nikki good morning
good morning prosecutors have spent
weeks painting a picture of Alec Murdock
as a liar who killed his wife and son to
distract from his own financial troubles
yesterday Murdoch told the jury his side
of the story
I didn't shoot my wife or my son anytime
ever just a minute after taking the
stand Alec murdaugh denied killing his
wife Maggie and Son Paul but he admitted
that he lied to investigators about
being at the crime scene just before the
murders blaming his dishonesty on
paranoia tied to his drug addiction
but once I lied I continued to lie yes
sir wow
you know or what a tangled web we weave
Murdoch testified that at his wife's
request he visited the dog kennels on
the Family's property that night he
admitted that it was his voice on this
cell phone video that has been played in
court multiple times that prosecutors
say prove he was with Maggie and Paul
minutes before their deaths
now
Murdoch's Alibi has been that he then
decided to visit his sick mother he says
when he returned home Maggie and Paul
were not at the house that's when he
went back to the dog kennels and made
the gruesome discovery I could see you
can see his brain laying on his sidewalk
I didn't know what to do I mean that's
CBS News legal analyst Ricky cleeman
from my impression when he was being
questioned by his own lawyers he
certainly came across as someone who
could not bear the loss of his wife and
his child for another juror the exact
opposite might be so
throughout his testimony murdaugh
referred to his wife and son by their
nicknames for most of all
I'm sorry to Max
and Papa
I would never
intentionally do anything
to hurt either one of them
but the prosecution questioned why
Murdoch never referred to them as mags
and Paul Paul in his interviews with
investigators this jury of course has
heard
multiple recorded statements of you
during the course of this did you ever
refer to Paul Paul during that
I don't know Murdoch who is facing
charges for about 100 other alleged
Financial crimes also admitted that he
stole millions of dollars from his
clients you had to sit down and deal
with these people and convince them that
you were telling them the truth in order
to steal this money correct
that may not be true because in some
situations I may not have had to do that
they may have just trusted me to do it I
can't say that I could say I did wrong I
stole money that wasn't mine
and I shouldn't have done it
the prosecutors estimate they still have
several hours of questioning left for
Alec murdaugh the defense tells me they
still plan to call a few more witnesses
but could still rest their case on
Monday Nate
we'll have to stay tuned to this
heartbreaking trial Nikki thank you